well millions of Americans are dreaming
about winning tomorrow's Mega Millions
jackpot now the largest in world history
the prize is about 1.6 billion dollars
as of this morning
that's just beats a Powerball drawing in
2016
mark Strassmann is at a store in
Marietta Georgia where customers are
hoping for a historic payout mark good
morning good morning as this Mega
Millions jackpot has grown crazier
interest in it has also spiked because
let's face it a billion dollars is a
billion dollars except not to be greedy
here it's not quite a billion dollars if
there's a single lucky winner of
tomorrow's drawing how much they take
home depends where that ticket was
bought if the winner chooses the lump
sum of nearly nine hundred five million
dollars in Florida where there's no
state taxes on winnings the take home
would be more than six hundred eighty
seven million in New York the highest
tax state that number falls all the way
to six hundred seven million and if
you're not a winner that doesn't mean
your money is wasted last year here in
Georgia more than 1.1 billion dollars in
total lottery revenue was set aside for
educational programs more than 25
percent of the lottery money collected
by the state over 1.6 million
four-year-olds have attended a pre-k
program funded by the lottery since its
launch in 1992 there's also a payoff for
retailers a winning store in California
would get a million dollars but if that
ticket is sold here in Georgia a gas
station like this one would get nothing
but bragging rights unless the winner
feels generous and let's face it Nora
they could afford to I know lots of
discussions about what to do with that
money if you won the mark thank you or
bring back some bananas when you're done
they're here the chances of winning you
have a better chance of having giving
birth to identical quadruplets
becoming president or becoming a movie
star and winning an Oscar so the odds
aren't so good that said I'm a buy
ticket I know